book about two peers working on Saturday
in recent years Russell Brands
reinvented himself as an
anti-establishment commentator online he
has 6.6 million subscribers on his
YouTube channel 11.2 million followers
on Twitter 6 million fans on Facebook
and they're all very loyal to it
millions of Brands fans have been crying
conspiracy since his scandal bro led by
influential figures like Elon Musk
Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tay why do so
many believe that he's a victim of a big
conspiracy we'll discuss this I'm joined
by the controversial influencer Pearl
Davis I'm from New York the well equally
controversial influencer Louise makes
let's call you both the same title shall
we
um all right let me start with you Pearl
uh I've been watching this it's very
interesting how Mr bait has come down
now uh with a lot of people on the
conservative right in the main but
basically saying they believe he's been
deliberately targeted and taken down to
silence him because he's been promoting
what they see as conspiracy theories
I mean it certainly seems like that I
mean I think you just you just start to
see the same thing over and over again
where prominent figures like like the
Tate Brothers right come out and then
all of a sudden they have all these
allegations from 10 years ago and
there's no evidence they don't go to the
police and all of the sudden it's it's
believe women with no evidence
and and it becomes like trial by the
media which I just think is wrong but is
it right to equate
his YouTube channel his
you know exploration of various theories
about covid or whatever is it really
realistic that the four-year
investigation by two mainstream media
companies is in any way connected to
that or a desire to sign and say why
would they care
it just seems like they they always just
go after them I don't know why
all right let me bring in Louise I mean
I don't I don't really follow this
Theory because I don't understand why
mainstream media would really care if
Russell Brand has millions of people
that want to watch his stuff I mean I've
watched some of occasionally it's not
always right-wing people he has
left-wing people on as well
um it's quite interesting some of it uh
I was gonna get him on my show and maybe
do hit so I don't really understand this
theory that somehow it's all a
deliberate campaign to silence it
what did they have a time machine Pierce
like do they have a time machine to go
back in time four years before he had
this YouTube channel at all and before
he started tacking hard to the alt-right
and then somehow they decided that they
were going to get him no they didn't and
I think the key thing here is not to
confuse two separate issues the first is
the issue of putative criminality of a
criminal case that as your previous
guests said will almost certainly never
be brought because this is historical
stuff and saying which I think you're
saying I disagree with you that the rest
of us can't decide that these women are
victims now I don't believe in the metoo
movement I have a problem with the idea
that accusation is the same as
conviction that's not true I believe
these specific women because I heard
what they have to say and I find them
credible in a way that I don't find
other accusers credible and I think
that's the difference
then go to the police like why are you
going to the media not the police you
know I mean at the end of the day the
media like they run stories and I just
don't think it's fair that we do trial
by the media
um
Harvey Weinstein is in prison because
women went to journalists
and then the police they should go to
the police yeah but it can be very
Sometimes women feel we just have that
why would you that doesn't make any
sense you go to the journalists instead
of the police but we live in a country
here where only one percent of rape
allegations lead to conviction well
you're maybe only one percent were
telling the truth I don't know does that
seem likely could be
unlikely I don't know says to me the
justice system is wrong in the way we
investigate these things Louise
look Pearl is somebody who believes that
women shouldn't even have the vote okay
let's just let's just leave it there yes
you heard in your own show today on your
own show today peers one of your earlier
guests who was actually defending
Russell Brand said that she had been
raped and the police treated her very
nicely but when you pressed her and said
then what happened we heard what happens
all the time to women that make these
accusations the director of public
prosecution said there were two people
in the room I can't prove anything and
they didn't bother to bring it together
I don't just see I don't think he's
assuming that I remember I disagree with
Louise I listen to them I don't think it
is sensible to automatically believe any
accusers about anything my natural
journalisty head says to me that's a
dangerous road to go down we've seen
timing again cases in this country where
people have been have turned out to be
completely innocent who were the subject
of massive publicity over bogus
allegations and you're telling me that a
guy that has women throwing themselves
at him 24 7 had to rape somebody that
doesn't make sense to me well I don't
think I don't think you can make the
leap that that couldn't happen I didn't
say it couldn't I'd say it's very
unlikely like it's Elon Musk is he gonna
rob a bank probably not I think it's
certainly less likely but he could do it
Louise final word to you quick
he had thousands of women yeah but he
decided he had to go and pick up a 16
year old from school look I don't have
to see him convicted in a court of law
to believe these accusers because these
specific accusers are credible okay the
story is incredible why are they
incredible we've got it over there
we will come back to this because it's
bound to keep going miss Scandal thank
you Pearl thank you Louise